animal advocates demanding  accountability tonight they're saying  they're not satisfied with the outcome  of a recent animal cruelty case with the  man at the center of it victor garcia  herrera set to be sentenced tomorrow  this all started back in january when a  report was filed with animal control  after a woman says a dog she rescued  died in the care of a pet sitter  business that business had also received  previous complaints about mistreated  animals in the past tonight the  advocates say they hope the business  would be shut down  we're not satisfied with the plea deal  that he's been given  we understood that paza's boarding  facility would be shut down and in fact  his wife is just going to continue to  run it that building that facility is a  house of horrors for animals and it  should be shut down nevada voters for  animals is working with local leaders on  proposals for tightening regulation of  pet related services